I have something for you today that is
disgusting in the sense that it is a
display of I don't know if it's lack of
empathy or vulture capitalism or the
broken wage tip employment system that
we have in the United States or just an
example of bad people I don't know what
this is but it's from CNBC that's the
financial TV channel they had a whole
story about a trick to save you money
when you go out to eat now it turns out
that the trick isn't really much of a
trick it's just tip less keep more of
your money instead of giving it to the
underpaid waitstaff who often have a
base wage of not much over $2 an hour
what a trick right here's a trick to
save money when you go out to eat tip
less boom that you'll be able to retire
early before you know it check out the
headline from the article this simple
trick could save you over $400 a year it
really implies that it's actually a
trick and what you will find when you
read into it further is that it's not
much of a trick it's the the article
says my brother and I have been tipping
the same way ever since we first got our
Velcro wallets and bull cuts using the
method our father taught us some 20
years ago
but after watching enough friends fill
out their bills at restaurants
everything I once thought I knew about
tipping came crashing down on me so what
is the trick it's just giving less money
to the waiter or the waitress waitress
here's some video from the segment that
they did and I'll tell you in advance
how they lie now outline the trick they
say when you calculate how much you're
tipping don't include the tax right if
you order a hundred dollars in food and
taxes are 10 bucks
tip on a hundred dollars not a hundred
and ten dollars take a look at the clip
it's customary to tip 15 to 20 percent
on top of your bill according to the
etiquette experts at the Emily Post
Institute but what exactly does that
apply to for example take a look at my
bill it was $100 and then a hundred
eight after tax so do you tip on the
pre-tax or the post tax total pre-sex
bolejack after tax generally okay what's
the difference to some
from an etiquette standpoint tipping on
pretax is absolutely fine you don't have
to tip on what you are already being
taxed upon I never knew that before
neither did I but it can be a game
changer when it comes to doing the math
in your head basically what they're
saying is you don't have to feel bad if
you tip on the pre-tax total go ahead
and do it you aren't supposed to tip on
taxes and they say it will save you
money without making you look cheap it's
not super clear to me that it doesn't
make you look cheap I say but here's the
thing are they wrong they're not wrong
okay you don't have to tip on the tax I
get that but to call this a trick is
merely to say here's a technicality for
which you can not feel guilty about
giving less money to underpaid waitstaff
right congratulations you were never
supposed to tip on the tax and you can
stop doing it right now and not feel
like you're doing a bad thing now I have
a view on this that might anger people
no matter what side of this entire
tipping Fiasco you're on I'm completely
against tipping okay I seek out
restaurants where tip is included in the
bill and waitstaff are paid a fair wage
I went to one in Boston recently called
the tasting counter where they do this
you just show up and it's all-inclusive
pricing I think that the tip system we
have is disgusting but I'm not gonna
punish the person making $2.00 in
something an hour because beyond their
control this is the system we have right
when I go out I tip well I tip 20% I tip
on the tax and if someone's extra nice
I'll even tip more I was in Washington
DC a couple of weeks ago our waiter at
at a great restaurant I went to
recognize me he was a fan he ended up
giving us a free bottle of wine or will
we we ordered a bottle of wine he
charged us for a glass of wine but gave
us a bottle so I tipped him a bunch more
right because it's not his fault that
this is the system we have so here's my
message if your financial situation is
such that tipping on the pre-tax amount
versus tipping on the post tax amount
changes your financial stability that's
not a restaurant you should be at okay
you should either be going out to eat
less
currently or you should be going out to
eat to less expensive places ok don't
punish the people at the bottom for a
system that they have no control over
and I've done this at times in my life
ok
there were times in my life where I made
the calculation that I'm not going to go
out and choose to save on tipping maybe
I just need to go to a less expensive
place or a lead in tonight and I'm not
gonna go and skimp on the tip CNBC
should be ashamed of themselves and
there's the sort of smaller lie and the
bigger picture problem here the small
lie here is that this is really a small
difference to most people ok the idea
that they deserve to be selfish and keep
the money from underpaid waitstaff in
the end we're not talking about a huge
difference on pre or post tax tipping
and that gets us to the bigger reality
which is while you have average people
and waitstaff for whom that might
actually be an important difference
tipping post tax or pre-tax you have
bigger picture huge corporations and the
very rich hand picking who they want
making law that benefits them at the
expense of everybody else right rather
than advice on how to keep more of your
money away from the waitstaff that's
being underpaid to begin with what about
the fact that the entire system is so
grossly unequal that the difference
between tipping post or pre-tax is so
impactful not just to the people going
out to eat but to the waitstaff as well
is the tragedy right we shouldn't have a
system where there is such an equality
such power for corporations and the rich
and then you have people who have to
figure out I might I might calculate the
tip pre-tax rather than post so that I
can afford to be here and then you have
the waitstaff we say if people all start
going pre-tax that actually really hurts
me and I need that money because of the
financial situation that I'm in that's
the tragedy and CNBC here this is a
disgusting and vile video I don't know
how else to say it
they should be ashamed of themselves if
you disagree with me I genuinely do want
to hear from you